cdu deutschlands wird in die geschichte
eingehen als ein ganz außergewöhnlicher
parteitag
wir verabschieden mit großer dankbarkeit
und anerkennung angela merkel nach 18
jahren an der spitze unserer partei und
wir besetzen dieses amt neu und den
vorstand insgesamt unterrichten zugleich
den blick nach vorn in die zukunft von
diesem parteitag liebe parteifreundin
parteifreunde muss ein signal des
aufbruchs und der erneuerung unserer
partei ausgehen
[Applaus]
uns begleitet heute eine ganz
außergewöhnlich große internationale
öffentlichkeit
auf uns wird geschaut weil sich mit
unserer partei große erwartungen
verbinden
wir sind in europa wahrscheinlich eine
der letzten vielleicht die letzte große
christdemokratische volkspartei und das
wollen ja das müssen wir in den nächsten
jahren und jahrzehnten auch bleiben
[Applaus]
die cdu hat und angela merkel hat heute
morgen schon darauf hingewiesen in den
70 jahren der geschichte unserer
bundesrepublik deutschland 50 jahre das
land regiert wir haben damit eine
verantwortung die über uns setzt
hinausreicht mit uns als volkspartei der
mitte muss ich auch in zukunft
politische stabilität in deutschland und
in unseren europäischen und
internationalen beziehungen verbinden
keine andere partei in ostdeutschland
und in europa ist dazu so sehr
aufgerufen wie wir die
christlich-demokratische union
[Applaus]
wir treffen uns heute und dies hat der
landesvorsitzende morgen auch schon
gesagt zum dritten mal nach der
wiedervereinigung in hamburg viele von
uns erinnern sich noch an die jahre 1990
und 1994 begann ja damals auch für uns
eine neue zeitrechnung
der eine oder andere beobachter schrieb
damals vom ende der geschichte war ja
jetzt alle konflikte gelöst und alle
probleme weitgehend beseitigt sind
1990 und 1994 hier in hamburg konnten
wir noch nicht ahnen welche
herausforderungen ein vierteljahrhundert
später auf uns zukommen sollen wir waren
damals fest davon überzeugt dass nach
der überwindung der teilung unseres
landes und des kalten krieges eine lange
periode des friedens und der
internationalen zusammenarbeit begonnen
hat wir konnten uns nicht vorstellen
dass im jahr 2014 in europa erstmals
wieder grenzen mit militärischer gewalt
verschoben werden wir waren im gegenteil
sicher das es mit russland zu einem
dauerhaften friedlichen zusammensein
kommen würde und wie eine
friedensdividende mit abrüstung und
geringeren ausgaben für unsere
verteidigung vereinnahmen konnten
der europäische binnenmarkt und ich war
selbst im europäischen parlament in
dieser zeit dabei ist in der zeit in
kraft getreten wir waren auf dem weg zur
großen ost erweiterung der europäischen
union
wir konnten uns beim besten willen nicht
vorstellen dass ein so großes
mitgliedsland wie großbritannien einmal
tatsächlich die europäische union
verlassen würde china befand sich mehr
oder weniger auf dem stand eines
entwicklungslandes
und wir waren sicher dass ein land unter
der führung einer kommunistischen partei
den anschluss an die hochentwickelten
staaten des westens mit demokratie und
marktwirtschaft so schnell nicht finden
werde
wir wussten schließlich die vereinigten
staaten von amerika fest an unserer
seite und wir konnten uns beim besten
willen nicht vorstellen dass dort einmal
ein präsident ins amt kommen würde der
mehr oder weniger alles infrage stellen
was unsere westliche staatengemeinschaft
ausmacht und was wir fest wo wir uns
fest und sicher aufgehoben fühlten
liebe freundinnen freunde ich sage dies
alles weil wir uns klar sein müssen dass
von diesen vielen gewissheiten heute
kaum noch etwas geblieben ist
wir leben für alle spürbar in einer zeit
des umbruchs und des tiefen wandels mit
diesen veränderungen und diesem wandel
sind trotzdem viele verbesserungen
verbunden und angela merkel hat ja in
der neuen zeitschrift die wir in den
letzten tagen bekommen haben zum
grundsatzprogramm prozess darauf
hingewiesen was sich alles in den
letzten 20 jahren verbessert hat die
extreme armut auf der welt hat sich fast
halbiert
der lebenserwartung in deutschland
steigt kontinuierlich an
die arbeitslosigkeit ist auf einem
tiefen stand und dem tiefsten seit der
wiedervereinigung löhne steigen renten
steigen und die verschuldung der
öffentlichen haushalte geht erstmalig
seit jahrzehnten zurück und trotzdem
verlieren die volksparteien in
deutschland seit längerer zeit
kontinuierlich an zustimmung die spd
liegt mittlerweile klar unter 20 prozent
und die cdu unter 30 zugleich werden die
populisten von rechts und links immer
lauter und immer erfolgreicher und nicht
wenige unserer früheren wählerinnen und
wähler finden plötzlich bei den grünen
eine neue politische heimat
damit ist heute auch von dieser stelle
aus praest
ich bestreite in unserer partei
niemandem den guten willen vor allem die
an die fdp verloren gegangenen
wählerinnen und wähler zurückzuholen
aber es gelingt uns augenscheinlich
nicht im gegenteil
im gegenteil seit der landtagswahl in
hessen sitzt diese partei nun in allen
16 landtagen
und wie partei die vor jahr und tag noch
viele von uns für eine vorübergehende
erscheinung gehalten haben ist im
deutschen bundestag die größte
oppositionspartei wie im vorteil
freundinnen und parteifreunde dieser
zustand ist für mich und ich denke für
alle auch von ihnen einfach unerträglich
er gefährdet er gefährdet nicht nur
unsere mehrheitsfähigkeit in der mitte
er gefährdet die stabilität unseres
landes und deshalb meine ich und sage
ich wir brauchen einen strategiewechsel
im umgang mit den themen im umgang mit
unseren politischen wettbewerbern und
vor allem in der kommunikation mit den
menschen in unserem land lassen sie mich
liebe freundinnen und freunde lassen sie
mich mit dem letzten bedienen es ist gut
und richtig dass wir mit diesem
parteitag heute einen neuen
grundsatzprogramm prozess beginnen
ich freue mich darüber grundsatzprogramm
prozesse sind aber zuallererst
selbstreflektion und
selbstvergewisserung einer politischen
partei
sie können nicht die ständige
dialogbereitschaft und vor allem die
fähigkeit ersetzen aktuelle politische
fragen zu klären zu erklären
entwicklungen aufzuzeigen und zugleich
ziele der eigenen politik in einer
verständlichen sprache zu erläutern
unser dialog und den dialog mit der
öffentlichkeit beginnt man zu hören
unsere generalsekretär ihn angeregt
haben karrenbauer und die will ich hier
ausdrücklich sagen hat dies in den
letzten monaten in einer geradezu
beeindruckende weise bereits begonnen
aus diesem
aus diesem zuhören muss einen dialog
werden aus dem dialog müssen antworten
von uns entstehen
wir lassen immer noch zu viele menschen
mit ihren fragen allein etwa wenn es um
sichere arbeitsplätze geht um
bezahlbares wohnen in den großen städten
um sicherheit von rente und pflege um
die betreuung unserer kinder um die
qualität der ausbildung in unseren
schulen um eine saubere umwelt und
natürlich gehört auch weiter das thema
migration und integration auf diese
themenliste
liebe freundinnen und freunde
es gibt
es gibt eine ganze reihe von weiteren
themen unsere umwelt politik darf ich
das so offen sagen ist voller
widersprüche
wir sind in den kosten für energie wende
und umweltschutz weltmeister aber wir
sitzen in kattowitz in der gruppe der
letzten im kato im mit in den
ökologischen schluss rechnern in der
letzten reihe und da steht immer noch
das unbeherrschte diesem thema zum
symbol geradezu in der mitte unserer
diskussion
thema innere sicherheit ob es uns
gefällt oder nicht viele bürgerinnen und
bürger gerade wählerin von und und
wähler haben das vertrauen in die
fähigkeit unseres staates verloren
sicherheit für das land und für jeden
einzelnen bei uns auch durchzusetzen
sie haben abends angst ältere menschen
bleiben zu hause
jugendliche erleben zu oft in den
schulen und im alltag bereits gewalt und
bedrohungen die bürger erwarten die
bürger erwarten dass der staat die
kontrolle über seine grenzen und auch
über die menschen die zu uns kommen
behält auch dieses vertrauen haben wir
in den letzten jahren verloren
das wort
stichwort steuern und abgaben liebe
freundinnen und freunde wir freuen uns
dass es der wirtschaft gut geht dass
arbeitsplätze entstehen und dass die
einnahmen des staates steigen aber immer
mehr menschen fragen wie viele netto
bleibt mir eigentlich am ende des monats
übrig lohnt sich überhaupt noch so viel
oder vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr
zu arbeiten und was passiert wenn es
wirtschaftlich einmal schwieriger wird
was absehbar ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
wie geht es dann mit unserer
volkswirtschaft weiter ich meine deshalb
wir als die partei von konrad adenauer
und ludwig erhard als die partei der
sozialen marktwirtschaft wir brauchen
eine agenda für die fleißigen eine
agenda
eine agenda liebe freundinnen und
freunde die sich dehnen zuwendet die in
unserer in unserem land mit arbeit und
fleiß das land stark machen eine agenda
für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer in unseren betrieben für
die polizisten auf unseren straßen
für die lehrerinnen und lehrer in
unseren schulen für die ärzte und das
pflegepersonal in unseren krankenhäusern
und altenheimen für die eigentümer
unternehmer die selbständigen und für
die vielen handwerker
kurzum für alle diejenigen die nicht
zuerst nach dem staat rufen sondern die
ihr leben selbst in die hand nehmen die
etwas daraus machen und an uns die
repräsentanten der politischen parteien
und unseres staates meistens nur eine
einzige bitte haben lasst uns in ruhe
arbeiten
richtig ist wir müssen in unseren reden
viel mehr darüber sprechen wo und wie
wir die probleme und herausforderungen
sehen wie wir sie lösen wollen und
welche langfristigen ziele wir verfolgen
wir müssen klare positionen einnehmen
und sie den menschen in einer
verständlichen sprache auch vermitteln
auf einen punkt ohne klare positionen
bekommen wir keine besseren
wahlergebnisse liebe freundinnen und
freunde
keine
eine solche überzeugungsarbeit gelingt
uns auch nur wenn wir wieder bereit sind
mit unseren politischen gegner zu
streiten
als volkspartei der mitte müssen wir den
politischen meinungsstreit wieder in
diese politische mitte zurückholen
dabei sind nicht um es klar und deutlich
zu sagen die populisten von rechts und
links unsere hauptgegner sondern vor
allem spd grüne und fdp
und auch wenn wir jetzt auch wenn wir
jetzt liebe freundinnen freunde mit der
spd in einer großen koalition in berlin
zusammen sind es unterscheidet uns
unverändert vieles von dieser spd
sie haben
wir haben ein christliches menschenbild
und damit ein festes wertefundament das
uns bindet und das uns zugleich von dem
wahn fernhält wir könnten alles auf
dieser welt mit gesetzen und
verordnungen regeln das geht nicht
die glauben unverändert wir glauben
unverändert an die freiheit und
verantwortung eines jeden einzelnen wir
trauen den menschen eben etwas zu und
wir halten sie nicht für betreuungs
würdige und bedürftige wesen vom ersten
bis zum letzten tag über die der staat
immer und jederzeit seine lenkt in der
hand halten muss das wollen wir nicht
wir sitzen wir setzen in unseren
unternehmen nicht auf klassenkampf
sondern auf partnerschaft mit sozialem
ausgleich
wir sind übrigens auch immer noch der
meinung dass der staat nicht der bessere
unternehmer ist sondern dass die vielen
kleinen mittleren
dass die vielen kleinen mittleren und
auch die großen unternehmen in unserem
land sehr wohl und sehr weitgehend ihrer
unternehmerischen und ihrer sozialen
verantwortung gerecht werden ja es gibt
ausnahmen aber das sind ausnahmen und
das sind nicht systemfehler liebe
parteifreundin und parteifreunde
wir stehen wir sind der auffassung dass
der nationalstaat nicht überholt ist
sondern unverändert der ort ist der
identität gibt der den menschen ein
zugehörigkeitsgefühl ja ein heimatgefühl
vermitteln und er vor allem sicherheit
im alltag gewährleistet unsere
gesellschaft ist weltoffen und tolerant
sie ist hilfsbereit wie nur wenige
andere länder auf der welt aber es gibt
auch grenzen unserer möglichkeiten liebe
parteifreundin und parteifreunde
wir stehen klar und eindeutig zum
gewaltmonopol unseres staates
und deshalb lassen wir den grünen nicht
durchgehen dass sie in den parlamenten
die gesetze mit beschließen und
anschließend nicht nur dagegen
demonstrieren sondern auch keinen
abstand halten mehr zu denen die gewalt
gegen unsere polizisten ausüben und ein
vermeintliches widerstandsrecht für sich
in anspruch nehmen
wir wissen wir wissen das innere und
äußere sicherheit zu gehabt
zusammengehören
wir müssen mehr tun für unsere
verteidigung und es kommt ja nun gott
sei dank auch in einem
entschließungsantrag hier zum ausdruck
wir haben aber auch eine fürsorge
verantwortung für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten und deutschland liebe
freundinnen und freunde deutschlands
stimme in der welt wird besonders
glaubwürdig wenn wir die zustimmung der
gesamten europäischen union hinter uns
wissen und ich will ihnen ein beispiel
sagen wo dies auch aus meinem eigenen
miterleben
besonders eindrucksvoll gelungen ist
anna du weißt dass auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz 2014 in münchen als
es um die frage ging zu der uns die
amerikaner drängen wollten die ukraine
zu bewaffnen um diesen konflikt dort
militärisch zu lösen
du hast dich damals auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vehement dagegen
gestemmt
auch gegen einige sehr polemische reden
unsere amerikanischen freunde dort du
hattest die gesamte europäische union
hinter dir und am sonntag haben die
amerikaner eingelenkt und zugestanden
dass dieser ton nicht in ordnung war und
dass die strategie auch besser war
mit anderen massnahmen als mit
militärischer aufrüstung in der ukraine
ein konflikt zu lösen
liebe freunde ich sage dieses beispiel
und sie wissen vermutlich ich bin
wirklich ein freund amerikas aber die
amerikaner brauchen hin und wieder eine
klare und eindeutige ansage und die ist
dann glaubwürdig wenn sie nicht nur aus
deutschland vorgetragen wird sondern
wenn die gesamte europäische union sagt
so wollen wir das nicht die amerikaner
akzeptieren stärke und nicht schwäche
und das müssen wir auch in diesen
schwierigen zeiten
so praktizieren
liebe
parteifreundin und parteifreunde als der
als volkspartei der mitte können und
wollen wir wieder bis zu 40 prozent der
stimmen der wählerinnen und wähler in
unserem ganzen land erreichen das setzt
aber voraus
das setzt aber voraus dass wir das
spektrum unseres politischen angebots
erweitern und uns dazu bekennen
das christlich-soziale liberale und auch
konservative wertkonservative frauen und
männer aus allen sozialen schichten in
unserer partei ihren platz haben
ich werde deswegen
ich möchte deswegen an dieser stelle
hier sehr offen ansprechen uns wird
geraten von verschiedener stelle das
auftreten der afg sogar als wie heißt es
dort nicht von uns sondern von beratern
als chance für die union zu begreifen da
unsere fokussierung auf die politische
mitte damit glaubwürdiger werde und es
rot grün oder gar rot rot grün noch
schwerer werde zu parlamentarischen
mehrheiten zu kommen wir haben das mal
asymmetrische demobilisierung genannt
und ich gebe zu ich habe das in einem
meiner bundestagswahlkämpfe sehr
erfolgreich auch selbst praktiziert aber
alles hat seine zeit
die auszehrung
die auszehrung des politischen
meinungsstreit in der mitte verlagert
mittlerweile den politischen
meinungsstreit auf die ränder die immer
stärker werden vor allem im osten
da fehlt uns plötzlich ein politisches
narrativ in diesem teil des wähler
spektrums der immer noch die mehrheit
unserer bevölkerung ausmacht nämlich
derer die ganz normal leben die fleißig
sind die toleranz sind und anständig
sind die aber auch nach antworten
verlangen auf die drängenden fragen
unserer zeit
und das war
und das war ja ganz offenkundig auch der
grund dafür dass sie in den
regionalkonferenzen diesen großen
zuspruch bekommen haben plötzlich kommen
da wieder mitglieder zur verantwortung
an staltungen der cdu die es interessant
und spannend finden mitzuerleben wie und
worüber diese partei diskutiert diese
mobilisierung unserer partei liebe
freundinnen freunde zeigt aber auch
eines ganz klar wir müssen wieder
diskutieren wir müssen um antworten
ringen wir müssen wieder eine gesunde
streitkultur entwickeln nicht um
personen sondern um sachfragen und mit
der richtigen streitkultur wird auch
nicht aus jeder sachfrage sofort eine
personalfrage
ich möchte ich möchte einen weiteren
aspekt aus gegebenem anlass hinzufügen
wir müssen ein noch besseres gefühl für
die sorgen und die unsicherheit der
menschen in den ostdeutschen
bundesländern entwickeln die bereits
einen tiefen strukturbruch hinter sich
haben
sie haben anspruch auf unseren
uneingeschränkten respekt sie verdienen
ihr vor der großen
veränderungsbereitschaft und dem
neuanfang den sie seit 1990 in fast
allen lebensbereichen erreicht haben ich
sage das weil unsere landesparteien dort
anspruch darauf haben dass wir ihre
besondere situation beachten und wir mit
ihnen kämpfen vor allem im nächsten jahr
wenn neben der kommunalwahl und der
europawahl auch landtagswahlen in
brandenburg thüringen und sachsen an
stehen ich möchte ihnen allen hiermit
aus den ostdeutschen bundesländern sagen
da wird sich die gesamte bundesparteitag
addieren und zwar so stark wie seit den
wahlen nach der wiedervereinigung nicht
mehr wir überlassen insbesondere den
osten unseres landes nicht den
populisten von links und rechts liebe
freundinnen und freunde
wir steuern
wir steuern auf die wir steuern auf die
kommunalwahlen in neun von 16
bundesländern am 26 wir steuern auf die
europawahlen ebenfalls an diesem 26
wir müssen kommunalpartei und europa
partei zugleich sein
wir müssen die europapartei in
deutschland sein liebe freundinnen und
freunde die europawahl 2009 10 und ich
war selbst fünf jahre in diesem
europäischen parlament diese
europawahlen werden eine bedeutung für
die zukunft europas haben die vermutlich
keine vorher seit 1979 auch hier gilt
wir wollen und wir können als die mit
abstand stärkste gruppe aus deutschland
in das europäische parlament einziehen
aber das geht nur wenn wir keinen
zweifel daran lassen wie wichtig europa
für uns ist und dass wir ganz genau
wissen dass die großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit eben digitalisierung
globalisierung klimawandel die gesamte
migration nur mit und nicht ohne oder
gar gegen unsere europäischen partner
gelöst werden können
wir müssen zugleich klarmachen europa
ist kein selbstbedienungsladen kein
kuchen aus dem man sich die rosinen
sozusagen herauspicken kann oder ein
europa la carte für jeden etwas dabei
wir sind in europa eine
rechtsgemeinschaft die sich an die
regeln hält weil sonst der zusammenhalt
in dieser europäischen union verloren
geht und das gesamte projekt gefährdet
wird
zusammenhalt zusammenhalt meine damen
und herren liebe parteifreunde
parteifreunde ist auch unsere antwort an
die junge generation
wir brauchen ja jüngere mitglieder wir
brauchen vor allem mehr frauen in
unserer politischen arbeit aber nur
darum zu werben lohnt alleine ist nicht
die richtige antwort wir müssen um die
jungen vor allem kämpfen und ihnen
mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten in unserer
partei anbieten
wir haben eine verantwortung für die
zukünftige generation die sich nicht nur
in der umweltpolitik zeigt
nachhaltigkeit gilt auch für die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer
volkswirtschaft insgesamt für die
alterssicherungssysteme und für die
generationengerechtigkeit schlechthin
und das gute miteinander von junge union
und senioren-union zeigt wir sind mit
diesen beiden vereinigungen sogar in der
lage gemeinsame
generationenübergreifende politische
positionen zu erarbeiten
wir leisten damit in der partei einen
beitrag zum zusammenhalt der
generationen der dann aber auch
vorbildlich ist für die gesamte
gesellschaft in deutschland
meine damen und herren liebe
parteifreundinnen und parteifreunde zum
abschluss lassen sie mich auch noch
einmal das stichwort zusammenhalt
aufnehmen für unsere partei da wird ja
in diesen tagen und wochen geschrieben
behauptet dato jetzt ein
auseinanderfallen ein auseinanderdriften
eine spaltung oder gar neuwahlen in
deutschland ich will dass ich aus meiner
sicht klar und deutlich sagen und bin ja
auch oft gefragt worden wie geht das
denn gut mit dem friedrich merz als
parteivorsitzender und angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin dazu ein ganz klares und
eindeutiges wort natürlich geht das gut
denn wir haben alle nicht nur großen
respekt vor der persönlichen leistung
von angela merkel
wir haben genauso respekt vor
staatsämtern und für uns geht immer das
land vor der partei und immer die partei
vor jedem einzelnen von uns und daran
wird sich jeder halten auch ein
vorsitzender friedrich merz wir haben
eine
wir haben ihre parteifreundin und
parteifreunde wir haben eine gewählte
regierung und wir haben ein bis 2021
gewähltes parlament
die aufgabe eines jeden
parteivorsitzende der cdu wird sein
mitzuhelfen dass deutschland in
schwierigen zeiten eine stabile
regierung und ein gut arbeitendes
parlament hat und führen möchte ich
diese partei als vorsitzender eines
teams das unsere stärken insgesamt zeigt
das wie in einer guten fußball
mannschaft auch flügelstürmer zulässt
die tore schießen das muss nicht immer
nur der vorsitzende selbst und alleine
tun und als eine moderne partei
und als eine moderne partei liebe
parteifreunde parteifreunde ja die ein
breites spektrum anbietet und deswegen
ist für mich völlig klar dass annegret
kramp karrenbauer und jens spahn auch im
falle meiner wahl in der engsten
führungsmannschaft der cdu ihren platz
haben müssen sie werden ihren platz dort
haben
und dann
dann muss es auch wirklich freude machen
dann muss es freude machen für unser
land politisch zu arbeiten
das geht aber nur wenn es uns auch
selbst voll gemacht wenn wir
untereinander der arbeit haben
liebe freundinnen und freunde und
deshalb stehe ich heute hier diesen
auftrag möchte ich gerne annehme in
ihrer aller namen und mit ihnen zusammen
dafür sorgen dass die cdu deutschland
die große volkspartei der mitte in
deutschland bleibt und ihren auftrag in
deutschland in europa und auf der welt
so wahrnimmt wie wir das heute
richtigerweise angela merkel für ihre
tätigkeit als parteivorsitzende gedankt
haben deshalb bitte ich um ihr vertrauen
herzlichen dank
er meine damit entfällt auch einfach mal
mit dem applaus an als indikator dagegen
gleichstand jedenfalls es ist wie man
kann kaum unterscheiden
ja jetzt mehr
klaus bekommen hat eine welt gartenbau
märz geklärt sein